tandis que on peut être les meilleurs du
monde je crois que à partir de
maintenant la technique c'est une chose
parce qu'il est le plus important qui va
rentrer à l'île contre intense et la
capacité mentale à vouloir
encore une fois si on veut le goût c'est
cette marche et cette masse il faut
mettre les choses dans l'ordre et pas un
et un secteur bon un secteur pardon tous
les matchs c'est là présentation c'est
de l'implication et pour cette période
sans arrêt de truc sans arrêt sans arrêt
cette semaine sans arrêt on sera
champion du monde mais ça passe par de
ça passe par du travail de la
concentration de l'implication que pour
ça que pour ça c'est pour ça que vous
êtes à parler et Internet et si et là
moi ce sont les mois il y aurait pas
d'internet tu aurais pas le téléphone
aujourd'hui cette semaine à vivre en
huis clos d'accord là entre loin entre
nous et se dire on le veut peut-être
chapeau du monde on le veut pas